Okay, questions which blood test shows how the immune system works? I have find this test and K cell test
absolute lymphocyte test
CD3, CD16, CD56. Yeah, these are all tests that you can
run to show
the function of the immune system. Certainly if you just want a general function of the immune system,
you're running a simple CBC panel. So a simple CBC panel will show your total white blood cell count
and it will show your differentials. Now it only shows the differential to lymphocytes,
stutrophils, monocytes, spasophils. It's not going to break the lymphocytes down into their
particle cells. It's not going to show other immune
modulator cells like all your CD cells. You have to get a more advanced panel for that.
However, does a person need to get those advanced panels if they have a diagnosis of cancer?
I do not think you need to get those advanced panels if you have a diagnosis of cancer. Those
advanced panels are really for a diagnosis of an autoimmune disorder. So if you have an autoimmune
disorder, if you think you have a genetic disorder in what's called your compliment factors
causing immune issues, then that can be a good test to get. Cyrex has what's called the lymphocyte
map test and that breaks. That's probably your best breakdown of all your immune cells that you
do a screenshot and show you what that looks like. That's what the Cyrex lymphocyte map
tests for. That's probably your most your your heftiest picture of
testing for immune function would be that that test is somewhere around 400 bucks or something
like that. But that's really honestly that's that would not necessarily be recommended for a
cancer patient. It would be more recommended for somebody who has a immune serious immune
dysregulation that that would be somebody with a serious autoimmune disorder. That's really what
that would be recommended for. So I you know for persons got cancer issues and they're trying to get
their immune system to function to help destroy the cancer. It's not that's not really what it's
you're this is a diagnostic tool to see what's wrong. It's not necessarily things that are
correctable by like you know using specific immune stimulation. This is telling us what's wrong
because of something in immune dysregulation that's going out in the body
um and because of an autoimmune issue. So I don't know that I would recommend that. But if you
wanted on a strict curiosity to see all your total natural killer cell counted percentage in
all your cytotoxic natural killer cells and percentages of those and total natural killer cells
your CD 56 16 T cells. All this fun uh guru stuff you could certainly run that.
And that's in the store.